so now you just want special treatment
and so I think unless we want to do that
I I think we shouldn't have it it's
never going to happen so it's kind of
just like you know in what world and I
also read the anti-suffragettes like
actual writings because I couldn't
figure out when I first heard it I was
like that's crazy like why didn't women
want to vote and they were talking about
how this is the beginning of the
breakdown of the family they're trying
to break up the family and that's what
happened because you're not supposed to
it's supposed to be like a one-man one
like of husband and wife they're
supposed to become one and nuclear
family's gone